right here to respond to joe biden's
appeasement abroad texas senator ted
cruz
energy is very important at texas so
with the stroke of a pen
high paying career energy jobs wiped out
uh with the stroke of a pen energy
independence
is wiped out and then joe biden gives a
waiver
to russia and vladimir putin to build a
pipeline
uh to supply energy and get rich
to our western european allies and
others
now senator maybe you can help sort that
out i didn't graduate from harvard you
did
well well sean sadly i can't shed a
whole lot of light on it it is
absolutely crazy what joe biden and
kamala harris are doing
on day one in office joe biden shut down
the keystone pipeline he destroyed
11 000 jobs high paying jobs including 8
000 union jobs
then biden sat by and allowed russian
hackers to
hack the colonial pipeline producing gas
lines up and down the eastern seaboard
he did nothing to defend it he sat by
while they paid
a ransom to russian hackers and now
his reward to russia for russian hackers
shutting down a
major infrastructure pipeline on the
eastern seaboard
is today he signed a waiver basically
greenlighting
the nordstream 2 pipeline a pipeline
from russia
to germany congress has twice passed
bipartisan sanctions to stop this
pipeline i authored those sanctions
we stopped the pipeline for a year it
was shut down it was a piece of metal
at the bottom of the ocean putin began
rebuilding the pipeline
right after biden was elected today he
issued a waiver
and and basically what joe biden has
decided is pipelines in america
bad jobs in america bad
pipelines in russia good jobs in russia
good
and and this is exactly backward it is
asinine
and four months into it joe biden is
crawling into bed
with putin and russia and the enemies of
america it doesn't make any sense and
then you've got russia now aligned with
china providing
arms to iran so that they can ship them
to yemen
so that the the proxy war can be
continue
in the middle east there as well uh let
me get to the issue of iran because
we've got some problems there too he
wants to get along with the muellers in
iran
again uh as we know that they are the
number one world sponsor of terrorism
and
what is it with this idea that joe biden
is going to lecture
prime minister netanyahu from doing the
right thing which is defending his
country that is under attack and assault
by a group whose charter calls for the
destruction of israel
sean you're exactly right what what
biden and kamala harris are pursuing is
exactly backwards
our friends and allies the people we
should be standing alongside and with
he's alienating undermining insulting
lecturing and attacking
our enemies the people who want to kill
us he's sending
money to supporting praising and kissing
their rear ends
so whether that is russia and biden
signing off on the putin pipeline
whether that is china
and biden nominating pro-china cabinet
nominees
who are unwilling to stand up to chinese
aggression or whether it is iran
and biden wanting to send billions of
dollars to the ayatollah khamenei who
chants
death to america you know if you think
about it sean nine months ago
in the middle east we had peace
flowering everywhere we had the abraham
accords i was at the white house for the
signing of the abraham accords
incredible victories that president
trump had won
by standing strongly and unequivocally
with israel
joe biden came in and in just four
months he's frittered all of that away
he's undermined israel and prime
minister netanyahu
he sent over a hundred million dollars
to the palestinian authority
with the pa which is in bed with hamas
hamas the terrorists that are firing
those rockets you're showing right now
they've fired over 4 000 rockets into
israel
and every one of those rockets might as
well have joe biden's name
written on the side of it because it is
his weakness his appeasement
his moral relativism and ambiguity his
lack of
backbone to stand up and stand with
israel that is
causing this war in the middle east let
me tell you what sean what he ought
to do he ought to stand up and say
rather than lecturing netanyahu rather
than being
arrogant and attacking our friends he
ought to say america
stands unequivocally with israel period
the end the hamas terrorists need to
stop
right now israel has an absolute right
to defend itself if hamas terrorists
attack israel they will be that they
will be dealt with and they will be
killed and he needs to right now
replenish
israel's iron dome missiles they are
firing missiles to intercept
these these hamas rockets they they
fired
thousands of iron dome missiles but but
you know instead
joe biden is to leave and the radical
left
all right it's clear to me and it's
inexplicable to me
neither biden or pelosi nor schumer
condemn the squad
and and virulent anti-semitism that has
existed among
among some of the members that we've
chronicled the detail on this program
my question now is okay
with with the instability created in the
middle east the new unholy alliance
russia china
and iran fighting the proxy war
eliminating energy independence here at
home
the price of oil is already going up
knocking out high-paying career energy
jobs for
people in your state of texas and
elsewhere okay what's the net result we
heard on national security
and we pay more for everything we buy in
every store coupled with inflation
and also we pay more for gas to fill up
our tanks
more for heating more for cooling our
homes who wins here
the bad guys and the enemies of america
this has been the most disastrous first
four months of any presidency
in history joe biden has handed the
democratic party over
to the radical left to to elizabeth
warren and bernie sanders and aoc
we've got a border crisis of an
absolutely unsecured border
and over 2 million people projected to
come here illegally this year
we have a gas crisis of gas lines and
skyrocketing energy prices we're on the
verge of an inflation price
crisis as the inflation numbers are
rising up and up and up and up
and we've got war in the middle east
we're four months in
it's a little terrifying to think what's
going to happen in the next four months
all of these are failures of the biden
administration i got to tell you what
this is
this is a reprise of the 1970s you and i
are both old enough to remember the
1970s
joe biden is jimmy carter 2.0
kamala harris is walter mondale and the
disasters they're producing
are failing at home economically
domestically
and abroad and we've got to stop it we
need to stand with israel stand with our
friend and i'm leading the fight to do
exactly that
and i'm headed to israel very shortly to
stand with israel and ensure they have
what they need to defend themselves
it's only one sentence even joe could
probably do it not mess it up
uh senator thank you for being with us
hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else